Das ist das Podcast mit Florentin, Stefan, Will und Tizia. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge Das Podcast-Ofo mit Stefan und Tietze und Florentin und Will. Hallo, schön, dass ihr da seid. Ich bin relaxed, ich bin entspannt, ich liege hier auf dem Bett. Florentin liegt gerade auf dem Bett, wir machen eine entspannte, hatten wir lange nicht mehr, Hotelzimmerfolge. Ich bin bei Florentin im Hotelzimmer und man muss dazu auch mal sagen, also wir wollen jetzt in den Details irgendwie nicht auf den Keks gehen, wo wir hier sind, warum wir hier sind, aber ich finde es immer spannend, in Hotelzimmer von anderen reinzugucken. Ja, es ist toll, es ist natürlich, Hotelzimmer sind nicht dafür ausgelegt, dass da ein Podcast aufgenommen wird, deswegen gibt es einen Stuhl und ein Bett und wir haben lange lange gekämpft, wer den Stuhl haben darf. Und am Ende liege ich jetzt auf dem Bett räkelnd, was gut passt. Wir haben nämlich einige Erotikeinsendungen von euch bekommen, die kann ich jetzt in passender Atmosphäre hier darstellen. Ansonsten sind wir gerade hoch in der Höhe. Wir sind im fünftenten Stock und schauen über die Stadt Berlin. Für mich ist es fast schon zu hoch ein bisschen. Ja, ich wurde an der Rezeption gefragt, haben Sie Probleme mit Höhen? Und ich habe einfach todesmutig gesagt, nein, weil ich eigentlich immer ganz gerne hoch oben bin im Hochhaus. Und ich habe gestern Abend, ich saß gestern einfach hier, habe entspannte Musik gehört, Vengaboys und einfach auf die nachttrunkene Stadt Berlin heruntergeschaut. Das ist herrlich. Wie wahnsinnig obszöne Songs sind, ne? Also zum Beispiel Parada de Tetas von Vengaboys. Die Tittenparade. Heißt einfach Tittenparade. Heißt einfach und als Kind, ich weiss noch, als achtjähriges Kind habe ich da mitgesungen, einfach dabei und jeder einzelne Song ist brutal versaut. Naja, der, was ist der Vengabus? Do I want you in my room, warum will ich nicht in meinem Raum? To spend the night together, together in my room. Das ist einfach alles super obszön, ich habe das alles nie verstanden. Ich habe jetzt von den Vengaboys auch keine romantische Poesie erwartet, ehrlich gesagt. Ich dachte, das ist so Kindermusik irgendwie, das ist die Pumuckl und die Detektive irgendwie, wo man da mal so Kindersachen hat. Nein, das ist einfach prickelnde Erotik. Oder zum Beispiel auch sowas, ich bin ja großer Fergie-Fan, auch da. Ich bin großer Furby-Fan. Deswegen verstehen wir uns auch so gut, weil wir genug haben, worüber wir sprechen können, aber wir kommen uns auch nicht in den Weg. Also wir streiten uns am Ende auch nicht. Nee, genau. Wir mögen Dinge, die sich reimen, und darüber füllen wir zueinander. Und da singen sie da auch irgendwie I Want Your London Bridge oder sowas. Und ich auch so völlig ratlos, völlig unerotisiert, unerrigiert sitze ich da vorm Radioapparat und denke mir, ja, das wird wahrscheinlich irgendeine sexuelle Anspielung sein. Aber London Bridge-Brücke ist jetzt für mich nicht der, wo du sagst, hey Baby, ich will deine Brücke sein.
Ja, ich habe damals einen Kumpel gehabt.
Zoll wegen Pfaden, Zoll oder so, keine Ahnung, was daran jetzt erotisch sein soll. Da hat ein Kumpel, der zu unserer Englisch-Lehrerin gegangen ist, so nach der Stunde gefragt hat, was denn, ist da irgendwie Britney Spears slash Sarah Connor slash I Don't Know Song, wo von Heat Between the Sheets die Rede war. Hat er nicht verstanden. Er hat gesagt, was heißt das bitte, Frau Fischer? Und sie hat gesagt, ja, ich glaube, die sprechen von Sex. Und dann mit Hochrotem Kopf ist sie dann uns in die Pause gefolgt. Ich glaube, der Job eines Englischlehrers, einer Englischlehrerin, ist vor allem, Leuten zu sagen, nee, in den Lyrics, die du gerade magst, geht's um Sex.
Entschuldigung, mein Lieblingsartist Fifty Cent spricht I want you in the candy shop, I let you lick the lollipop. Was ist denn da mit gemeinfrau Unterbrüchler?
Ja, liebe Florentin, da geht's um heissen Oralsex.
Was bedeutet Oralsex?
Da geht's darum den Pimmel der Fifty Cent. Die ungeduldige Englischlehrerin auch. Fifty Cent will, dass du seinen Pimmel in den Mund nimmst. Ja, aber das ist doch so. Ja, aber das möchte ich aber nicht. Hoch und anlaufen. Das möchte ich nicht, Frau Unterbrückler. Hast du noch andere Lyrics, die ich dir erklären soll? Bei uns war es damals so in Deutsch, war es andersrum. Da gab es den Schimmelreiter und dann wurde so eine Stelle vorgelesen und dann ging es dann irgendwie, ja, die Schenkel der Reiterin schlossen sich um den starken Leib und alles und so und die ganze Klasse so und dann ja weiter und irgendwie hitzig und irgendwann die Lehrerin, ja das ist durchaus auch als sexuelle Konnotation gemeint.
Und allen vergeht das Lachen. Ja, und alle dachten so, sie hihihi und die so, nein, das will der Autor genau damit sagen. Das ist intentional, Idioten. Und allen vergeht sofort das Lachen, weil sie wollen ja nicht mit diesem Autoren relaten. Ich glaube, da war ich erwachsen. Das ist der Moment, wo ich erwachsen geworden bin, wo ich merke, oh, Sexualität ist vielleicht nicht ein Thema, sondern nein, das ist schon durchaus gewollt so, das ist schon, kann auch mal angesprochen werden. Aber selten bei uns im Podcast, mittlerweile immer mehr, wir erdenken unseren Körper mittlerweile, ihr kriegt es vielleicht mit und genauso auch unsere Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer, die allerdings vielleicht das ein bisschen taktvoller ausdrücken können, ihre sexuelle Lust, ihre sexuelle Begierde, als Fifty-Cent es das vielleicht getan hat oder die Venga-Boys und Girls, und zwar in der mittlerweile wieder erwachten literarischen Form des Elfchens. Elfchen, genau, wir haben nämlich das Elfchen-Name wiederentdeckt durch unsere liebe Hörerin, die uns letzte Woche einen Brief aus Finnland geschickt haben. Genau, Elfchen bedeutet ein kleines Gedicht, ein kleines Limerick aus elf Wörtern,
die in willkürlicher Weise durcheinander gewürfelt werden dürfen.
Und wir haben eine Einsende bekommen unter dem sehr selten gesehenen Genres des Erotik-Elfchens.
Es sind elf Wörter, die sich zusammenfügen zu einer feuchtfröhlichen Melange, die uns die Schamesröte in die Lenden treiben wird. Stefan, bist du bereit? Erstmal möchte ich kurz erklären nochmal, also wir haben letzte Woche den Aufruf gestartet, schicken wir uns mal wieder Elfchen, das ist ein bisschen das deutsche Haiku, so und das ist ein bisschen in Vergessenheit geraten, deswegen müssen wir kurz erklären, was es ist, nämlich es geht darum, dass ein Elfier ein kurzes Gedicht in einer vorgegebenen Form ist. Es besteht nämlich aus elf Wörtern, die in Festgegitter-Reihenfolge auf fünf Verszeilen verteilt werden, nämlich Zeile eins, ein Wort, Zeile zwei, zwei Wörter, Zeile drei, drei Wörter, Zeile vier, vier Wörter, Zeile fünf, ein Wort. Ne? Ja. Und der Inhalt ist meistens so. Erste Zeile, ein Gedanke an Gegenständen, ein farbender Geruch. Zweites Wort, was macht das Wort aus Zeile eins? Dritte Zeile, wo oder wie ist das Wort aus Zeile eins? Zeile vier, was meinst du? Zeile fünf, was kommt dabei heraus? Also wir haben hier wirklich so eine kleine Heldenreise, die man in diesen fünf Zeilen durchmacht, fünf Aktstruktur in komprimierter Form, gar nicht einfach. Ganz, ganz spannend, wir können ja gleich in die Analyse gehen. Ich lese es einfach mal vor, das Werk, das uns zugesandt wurde von, ein Name, der in der Autorenschaft vielleicht schon bekannt ist, Federico Pizzol, hat uns hier ein Elfchen zugesandt. Wärme, feuchte Laken, in Schweissperlen rakeln, Menschen, die sich haben, bangen. Das war ein erotisches Elfchen von Frederico Pizzolini. Bangen. Ja. Erstmal möchte ich anmerken, dass ein interessantes Stilmittel und oder ein Fehler, ich glaube, es ist ein Rechtschreibfehler drin, weil er heisst es nicht räkeln? Ja. Und er hat geschrieben, in Schweißperlen rakeln. Ah ja. Was ich spannend finde, es ist ja wahrscheinlich, wir müssen hier aufgehen, das ist eine literarische Entscheidung. Naja, er hat davor Laken geschrieben. Laken, deswegen Raken, grossartig, sehr, sehr gut, auch hier Mut zum Fehler, natürlich Fehler falsch machen, auch in der Sexualität immer ein wichtiger Moment dabei, Fehler auch eingestehen, zugeben, sich verwundbar zeigen. Genau. Deswegen auch hier in der Rechtschreibschwäche nackt steht der Autor hier vor uns in diesem Gedicht, von daher grossartig. Hat mir sehr, sehr gut gefallen. Ja, finde ich ein super gutes Gedicht. Vielen Dank an das eine Elfchen. Ja, das wir bekommen haben. Ich finde gut, dass wir damals mal gesagt haben, als es um Stalagmiten und Stalagitzen ging, dass wir es einer nur aus der Community bitte dieses Bild schicken soll. Genau, der naheliegende Wortwitz Stalaktize, Stefan, der mit einem neutralen Gesichtsausdruck von der Decke hängt in einer Tropfsteinhöhle. Unsere Bitte macht es nur einer von euch, könnt ihr euch einigen. Mittlerweile antwortet immer nur einer von euch auf eine Frage, die wir gestellt haben. Ist aber sehr handlich. Handlich, aber wir wollen natürlich mehr Elfchen haben. Es ist eine tolle Gedichtssache, aber wir wollen die zurückholen. Genau. Ich habe auch noch eine Einsendung bekommen von einem Hörer von dem Karsten, der korrigiert uns. Deswegen die Rappadapa Rappadapa Leute, das ist ein Comedy-Podcast. Das ist ein Comedy-Podcast, wir machen hier Jokes, wir sind nicht wirklich dumm. Korrektur. Korrektur. Carsten schreibt nämlich, Thema Casino, wir haben ein bisschen was durcheinander gebracht. Und es müssen ein paar Sachen müssen gesagt, weil er ist nämlich Spielbankaufsichtsbeamter in den bayerischen Spielbanken. So, und ihm geht es darum, der Ballreinwerfer heißt Croupruppier. Ja, okay, gut. Das haben wir nicht gewusst. Brauchst du gar nicht so arrogant das jetzt abtun. Ja, wenn das deine Korrektur ist, dann bin ich schon ein bisschen arrogant. Punkt zwei. Euer Trick nennt sich Progressieren. Das ist der Trick, den wir gesagt haben. Immer einen draufbringen. Also immer eins auf Rot, dann wenn man verliert, zwei auf Rot, dann vier, dann acht und so weiter. Der beliebte Trick, den man lernt. Und der funktioniert auf Dauer nicht. Und die Doppel-Null gibt es im Deutschen nicht. Es gibt im Deutschen nur eine Null. Und man sagt auch nicht Null, sondern man sagt Zero. Zero. Also wie ein falsch ausgesprochenes Zero. Man sagt Zero zu Null. Das waren aber schon alle Anmerkungen, die wir bekommen haben von der Bayerischen Spielbank. Das ist die Korrektur-Mail? Komm, das ist mir zu pedantisch. Nee, das, nee, Entschuldigung, ich lehne diese Kritik ab. Ich lehne die Kritik ab. Dass wir gesagt haben, null oder zwei null, war ja nur, um zu demonstrieren, dass es mehr als eine schwarze und rot geht. Das ist mir egal. Liebe Carsten hat er nur geschrieben, nein, er hat geschrieben. Nein, doch, nein, solche Leute, solche Pedanten braucht die Welt nicht, Carsten, ich verurteile es, nee, wenn er die Spielcasinos beaufsichtigt, dann beaufsichtige ich mal die Pedantenschaft und stelle hier ein klares Veto aus und sag hier Veto, Carsten, Veto, Veto, weg mit dem Laptop, leg ihn auf die Hand, Zero Punkte für Carsten. Du kannst jetzt, finde ich, nicht die Spielbankaufsicht beaufsichten. Ja, aber wer denn sonst? Die machen sonst, was sie wollen. Meinst du, die machen, was sie wollen? Natürlich, du musst immer gegen Aufsicht, geht nur mit Gegenaufsicht, ganz klassische Prämisse aus der Aufsichtsformel. Geht für mich nicht anders. Okay, alles klar, da haben wir andere Meinungen. Ich finde es einfach nett, dass uns Hörer schreiben. Ja. Dass uns noch Hörer schreiben. Nach allem, was passiert ist. Nach den Skandalen, die passiert sind. Nach dem grossen E-Mail-Brand, nachdem tatsächlich, und das ist tatsächlich ein Ding, das tut mir wirklich leid, jetzt mehrere Monate das Postfach voll war, und sämtliche Mails, die wir bekommen haben, einfach über den Briefkasten rausgeschwemmt sind und rausgequollen sind und daneben den Briefkasten gelegt wurden und beim nächsten Windstoss in aller Herren Länder verteilt wurden. Also euer Brief kommt an, aber halt nicht bei uns. Aber irgendwo im Internet wird das schon ein Land gefunden haben. Es ist ja manchmal so, können Sie eine E-Mail für Ihren Nachbarn annehmen? Das ist das Postfach Ihres Nachbarns voll. Wir haben eine E-Mail, können Sie die kurz annehmen? Ja, keine Ahnung, ist sie denn so selten. Der ist doch, glaube ich, im Urlaub.
Aber wie gesagt, wir müssen sie sonst zum Empfänger zurückschicken und jetzt ist sie schon hier.
Ja, dann geben Sie mir die einfach jetzt.
Okay, dann hier.
Okay, danke.
Und dann musst du sie weitergeben.
Dann muss ich weiterleiten.
Ja.
Und dann kriege ich die E-Mail zurück, dass das fucking Postfach voll ist.
Also es war voll, es tut mir leid, aber mittlerweile ist alles wieder angekommen und alles kein Problem.
Also ich habe alles gesichtet und macht euch da bitte keine Sorgen.
Aber wir waren tatsächlich eine Zeit lang nicht erreichbar, hat aber niemand gemerkt.
Kamen Beschwerden rein?
Nein.
Wissen wir nicht, die wären auch nicht angekommen bei uns.
Also das ist ja das Gute, wenn da mal was verstopft ist, dann kommen leider auch die Beschwerden nicht rein.
Nicht so schlecht.
Es sei denn, jemand trifft mich auf der Straße und sagt, hey Florentin, euer Postfach ist voll. Ich wollte es euch nur mal persönlich sagen. Ah ja gut. So kann das passieren. So kann es nicht passieren. Anders kann es nicht passieren. Problem ist gelöst, kein Problem, schreibt uns bitte weiter eure Eindrücke, in welchen Städten seid ihr unterwegs. Wir sind in Berlin, wir schauen auf die gesamte Stadt hier herab, aus einer Vogelperspektive, können wir diese wunderschöne Stadt sehen, wahnsinnig flach, merkt man erst mal, man kann das wirklich abgleichen mit dem Fensterrahmen, ganz, ganz flache Stadt, das ist das Erfolgsgeheimnis von grossen Städten, dass sie so flach sind, weil wenn, ich frage mich immer, nach welchen Maßstäben baut man eine Stadt hin. Rio ist nicht flach. Aber es muss doch irgendwann mal eine Zeit geben haben, wo Leute einfach so durch den Wald spaziert sind und gesagt haben, weisst du was, hier bauen wir eine Stadt, genau hier. Und dann sagt jemand, ja warum genau hier, warum nicht 20 Meter weiter rechts, ja hier ist es so schön flach, hier können die Wägen gut rollen. Also was ich halt nicht so richtig verstehe ist, dass, weil Burgen ja vor allem auf hohen Punkten gebaut wurden, um Feinde, herannahende Feinde eher zu sehen. Ja, und um die gut verteidigen zu können. Du bist ja Mittelalter-Experte. Ich glaube, das Herannahmen war nicht so wichtig, aber das Verteidigen ist natürlich einfach. Um herannahende Feinde früh erblicken zu können. Damit sie den High Ground haben sozusagen. Genau. Damit sie 50 Prozent mehr Schaden machen mit Bogenschützen. Richtig. Das ist die Idee. Und jetzt verstehe ich halt nicht, also damit sie auch die Initiative, kann man sagen, haben. Genau die Initiative, ja. Jetzt verstehe ich halt nicht, wenn Burgen ja eher auf höheren Punkten entstehen, sagen wir sogar in der Nähe von Flüssen, weil beliebte Handelswege. Jetzt hat Berlin nicht die grössten Flüsse, ja gut, die Spree, aber es ist kein Riesenfluss, es ist nicht der mächtige Rhein, ich als Kölner bin in den mächtigen Rhein gewonnen. Ja gut, ja, da wurden Opern drüber geschrieben, über den Fluss, Spree ist ein Softdrink, Spreegold. Ja, was soll das? Das ist nicht die gleiche Dimension. Spree ist die schlaue Art zu waschen. Stimmt, ja. Nee, und deswegen verstehe ich nicht, warum Berlin so flach ist. Ich verstehe es auch nicht, aber ich glaube, es ist ein Erfolgsgeheimnis. Aber tatsächlich bei Burgen ist es ja so, nicht nur die Burg ist hoch, sondern der, der oben steht, hat ja den Vorteil, weil zum Beispiel auch Wendeltreppen sind immer linksrum gewendelt, linksrum gedreht, dass der, der oben steht, mit seinem Schwert in der rechten Hand gut nach unten schlagen kann, aber der unten steht nicht nach oben schlagen kann, weil die Wendeltreppe nach rechts oben geht und damit das nicht geht. Das heißt, wenn du Linkshänder warst im Mittelalter, hast du alle weggemetzelt, weil niemand damit rechnet.
Ja, du verteidigst eine Burg.
Ja.
Also Linkshänder greifen eher an.
Die gehen dann ins andere Team über, die sagen dann Team Blau, man wechselt vor dem Kampf, wechselt man die Linkshänder aus, damit es wieder fair ist, ansonsten ist es zu gemein.
Aber das heißt, Linkshänder sind ja meiner Meinung nach immer auch ein bisschen aggressivere Menschen, sind eher die Angreifer gewesen, weil die ja gut nach oben hin angreifen können, wohingegen sie nicht nach unten verkehren können. Das ist natürliche Selektion, obwohl wenn du die Burg eroberst, dann kannst du wieder faul werden. Aber glaubst du, es gibt deswegen weniger Linkshänder? Das ist ja spannend. Weil die alle draufgegangen sind. Keine Ahnung. Das weiss ich jetzt nicht. Nee, das weiss ich nicht. Das ist der erste Punkt im Podcast. Das ist der Punkt, wo ich wirklich die Waffen strecken muss und sage, keine Ahnung, da bin ich jetzt lang.
Du legst das Schwert nieder und sagst, du weisst es nicht, du gibst auf?
Ja.
Okay.
Manchmal muss man auch bescheiden sein und sagen, das weiss ich einfach nicht.
Ich finde es gut, dass du auch diese Bescheidenheit dann auch an den Tag legen kannst.
Ja.
Bist du Rechtshänder oder Linkshänder?
Ich bin Rechtshänder und wurde aber auch mal getestet auf Füssigkeit.
Das weiss ich noch, da war einmal, ich fand, es gibt wenige Menschen, die mich so sehr geprägt haben wie mein Snowboardlehrer, der mich wirklich also minütlich gemeindblowt hat. Also am Ende des Tages war mein Schädel weit offen und gut, dass ich einen Helm getragen habe, weil da war wirklich alles rausgebombt aus diesem Kopf, weil wirklich nahezu jeder Satz, also
ein vor Coolness strotzender
Typ, einfach wirklich rüstig
gebauter Typ,
einfach hat alles schon gesehen, vor allem
die geilste Ansage war schon am Anfang,
weil ich habe erst den Anfänger-Snowboard-Kurs gemacht
und halt so ganz einfach schlitterst,
der den Berg runter und dann kommt der
fortgeschrittenen Kurs und das erste, was
mein Lehrer im fortgeschrittenen Kurs gesagt hat, ist so, das erste, was ich von euch will, vergesst alles, was ihr über Snowboard fahren wisst. Und du hast davor drei Stunden lang auch davor nicht so viel gewusst, John. Was erstmal für Elfjährige einfach mal eine Ansage ist, wenn du sagst, okay, dann. Ja, ich hänge nicht Ich hänge mich an dem Wissen, an dem Automatisten, wenn die sich über die Jahrzehnte gebildet haben. Und ich habe mir in dem Moment geschworen, so will ich jedes Gespräch beginnen. Immer wenn ich ein Referat halte über Genghis Khan, fange ich an mit, vergesst alles, was ihr über die mongolische Geschichte wisst. Vergesst jetzt alles. Also, und einfach so, warum, und das finde ich auch so eine geile Ansage. Und da war es auch so, dass der erst mal meinte so, ja, mach mal einen Liegestütz. Und ich dachte schon, okay, krass, jetzt geht's hier los, jetzt werde ich hier gedrillt. Und mache ich einen Liegestütz und ah, okay, bist Rechtsfüßler. Wieder erneut Schnee spriesst, überall mein Kopf erneut geblowt. In dem kleinen Helmchen so, in eine sehr überschaubare Detonation. Ja, Blut läuft mir die Nase runter, aus meinen Ohren qualm, also es ist wirklich, ich stehe in Flammen und er meint, ja, weil du bist nach dem Liegestützen mit dem rechten Fuss zuerst aufgestanden. So test ich, ob du ein Rechtsfüsse oder ein Linksfüsse bist, du bist jetzt Regular, nicht Goofy, weiter geht's. Ich glaube einfach nur, war das der coolste Dude? Was ist hier los, ey? Ich komme nicht mehr raus. Es ist einfach ein Knaller nach dem nächsten, wirklich. Unfassbare Typ. Was macht der heutzutage? Keine Ahnung, melde dich, melde dich bitte. War der denn älter, war der viel älter oder war der so ein cooler 20-year-old? Ja, ich war elf. Ja, wie alt war der denn so? Jeder Mensch älter. Keine Ahnung, wenn du elf bist, sind alle Menschen alt. So, der war, keine Ahnung, vielleicht 25 oder so. Aber cool Typ, also falls ihr mal einen Snowboard-Kurs gegeben habt und so ein kleiner, dicker, bayerischer Junge da mit dabei war, der die ganze Zeit hingefallen ist und der sehr erfolgreich alles vergessen hat, was er über Snowboard fahren müsste. Du beschreibst dich wie eine Simpsons-Figur, ehrlich gesagt. Der kleine dicke bayerische Junge. Ja, das ist ja ein bisschen schwierig für die deutsche Übersetzung.
Wie übersetzt man den für die deutsche F. Oder macht man den zum Schweizer? Passen aber die ganzen Bayern-Gags nicht mehr so ganz. Aber naja. Ja, der Schweizer mit der Lederhose. Das passt auch nicht zum Schweizer. Ja, aber die Schweiz ist das Bayern Deutschlands. So ein bisschen. Die Schweiz ist das Bayern Bayerns. Das stimmt auch wieder, ja. War nachher gar nicht so schlecht übersetzt, aber Uta ist natürlich für mich immer eine Identifikationsfigur, weil ich mir natürlich auch dachte, du kennst den... Wie? Uta. Ah. Uta ist der Deutsche oder in der deutschen Fassung der Schweizer. Uta. Schlag mich nicht, ich bin voll mit Schocki. Das war da, wo ich mir dachte, yes, das ist meine Welt. So will ich sein. Das ist ein Catchphrase. Das ist ein Catchphrase. Scherz gekauft, schlag mich nicht, ich bin voll mit Schocki. Das war mein Catchphrase, so wollte ich immer sein. Dick und gejagt, dick und gehetzt. Aber kurz zum Selbstverständnis, der Schweizer, die beschreiben mich Deutschland als sechzehntes Kanton. Oder siebzehnt oder je nachdem wie viele Kantone sie haben. Das heißt, irgendwie will man immer die anderen Leute in seinem Team haben. Aber ist nicht schon Malotze das sechzehnte, das siebzehnte Bundesland? Da kommen wir jetzt an so ein waschechtes Millennium-Problem. An moderne, geografische Probleme. Es gibt ja selten, es gibt ja nur noch wenige Expansionskriege tatsächlich. Man hat ja das Gefühl, die Grenzen sind gezogen. Die Krim, die Krim, klar, da wird es noch, aber das ist ja winzig im Vergleich zu damals, als man gesagt hat, das gehört jetzt alles mir. Russland gehört noch nicht, ja. Ganz Europa gehört jetzt mir. Und von daher sind das vielleicht die neuen geopolitischen Verschiebungen, auf die wir aufpassen sollten. Zu sagen, Malotze ist das siebzehnte Bundesland, Deutschland das achtzehnte Kanton, Österreich das vierzehnte Bundesland. So, das ist schwierig. Das wird schwierig, ja. Immerhin wird es auch einfach undurchdringlich. Ja. Aber mir gefällt das sehr. Was hast du denn gestern, als du dir aus dem Fenster geguckt hast, gedacht? Ich dachte erst mal, ich kann schön Musik hören irgendwie und dann konnte ich mich aber lange nicht dafür entscheiden, welche Musik ich hören will, für diesen Moment angemessen. Klassik. Ja, Klassik, aber Klassik ist mir zu aufbrausend, da kann man nicht so gut entspannen. Und da habe ich halt dann doch Vengaboys gehört, weil ich dann doch Bock hatte, Vengaboys zu hören. Und es passt, ich denke mir immer so, es gibt ja so zwei Arten von Soundtracks in Filmen, die Songs, die genau passen. Also da hat jemand einen Kokosnuss-Drink und hört Put a Lime in the Coconut und du denkst dir, geil, oder halt genau gegenläufig, so dass du halt genau gerade Krieg siehst und währenddessen eine Oper hörst oder so, so eine Arie, wo du denkst, aha, da wird mit Kontrasten gearbeitet und so versuche ich im Alltag auch, so guckst du auf Filme, aha, hier wird mit Kontrasten gearbeitet, sagte er, während er sich Popcorn in den Mund stopfte. Aha, hier wird wohl mit dem Mittel des Paradoxen erzählen. Psst, ruhe, nee, psst. Und dann habe ich mir gedacht, so mache ich das auch, ich will in meinem Alltag eher mit Kontrastmitteln arbeiten und höre als Vengaboys zu dieser romantischen Nacht. Und ich habe freudig mit dem Fuß getippt und es war ein schöner Abend, war herrlich. Ich war neulich im Kino, um den neuen James Bond zu schauen. Und es war ein sehr neues Kino, sehr schön und auch sehr voll. Und was ich zum ersten Mal erlebt habe, war, dass es quasi, bevor der Film anfing, ein Spiel gab, wo alle mitmachen durften. Nämlich das Spiel, das ist das, was man von das Kenntnis, das Taschenspieler-Trick-mässig aus der Innenstadt. Also es waren verschiedene fünf Karten zu sehen oder sechs Karten, Spielkarten. Und da wurde eine umgedreht, da war dann irgendwie das Avengers-Poster oder sowas, dann wurde die wieder umgedreht und dann wurden die Karten durchmischt.
Auf der Leinwand.
Auf der Leinwand und man musste sagen, konnte antippen, man musste raten, wo die ist jetzt.
So, und dann war oben ein Code und musste sich eine App runterladen und dann konnte man den Code eingeben und konnte partizipieren in dem Spiel.
Und dann konntest du auf deinem Handy dann die Karte anklicken.
So, ich habe das gesehen und verarbeitet und dachte mir, ach krass, ja, da spiel ich mal mit jetzt. Da habe ich ewig gebraucht, mir diese App runterzuladen und dachte, gut, das kann ich nicht mehr gewinnen, weil alle anderen spielen ja jetzt hier schon fleißig mit und so. Und es gab zu gewinnen ein kostenloses Popcorn. Mega, fand ich eine super Idee. Lecker. Das konnte man dann noch raus und sich holen. Und dann habe ich da mitgemacht, habe ich wie gesagt viel zu lange gebraucht für diese App und so und das Spiel war schon fast vorbei.
Es gab irgendwie sechs Runden, die waren schon in Runde fünf, dann habe ich mich eingeloggt. Habe dann auch ganz schnell unten so ein Bild ausgewählt und so, das war eine Frau, so eine Comic-Frau, weil ich mich einfach schnell durch diese App geklickt habe, damit ich mich schnell mitmachen konnte. Und in dem Moment, wo ich auf den Code eingegeben habe, um mitzuspielen, kommt unten auf dieser
riesigen Leinwand in dem vollen Kino plötzlich diese kleine Frau, die ich gerade ausgewählt habe, hochgeploppt und dann stand Stefan. Das heißt, ich war der einzige Mitspieler und das ganze Kino hat gelacht, weil es ist nichts passiert, weil die ganze Zeit wurden diese Karten gemischt und es gab ein paar lustige Soundeffekte, aber im Prinzip war es ruhig und das ganze Kino hat auf den Film gewartet und plötzlich war, gab es dieses Geräusch und diese Stefanfigur und dann gab es auch diesen Kontrast zwischen der kleinen Comicfrau und dem Namen. Ja, sehr männlichen Namen. Ja, ich war oben in den letzten drei Jahren natürlich auch laut losgelacht, weil dann fühlt sich mein Name da zu sehen war.
Sondern war ich jetzt der, habe ich gemerkt, ich bin der einzige Spieler.
Und dann war meine Motiv war ich jetzt ja, habe ich gemerkt,
ich bin der einzige Spieler. Und dann war
meine Motivation natürlich jetzt gesteigert,
weil ich dachte, ich bin wenig close
als vor dem Popcorn. Beziehungsweise die Motivation
war weniger zu gewinnen, als nicht zu scheitern jetzt,
wenn du jetzt mit Nullpunkten verlierst.
Ja, das ganze Kino war auch jetzt plötzlich wieder hellwach.
Die wollten primär den Film sehen,
jetzt wollten sie primär sehen, wie Stefan
bei diesem Spiel abschneidet. Ja. Sie wussten auch nicht genau, wo Stefan sitzt. Also es wurde sich schon umgeguckt und so. Machen wir es kurz, Stefan war nicht so gut in diesem Spiel. Und es wurde auch immer schwieriger, weil wir waren auch schon in Runde fünf und ich habe noch nicht mitgespielt. Also mein Kumpel und ich haben dann gemeinsam auf die Leinwand geschaut, haben uns jeweils Karten gemerkt. Es wurden auch irgendwann mehr Karten, die man sich merken musste und so. Und in der ersten Runde, in die Runde fünf keinen Punkt gemacht und in der Runde sechs, der finalen Runde auch keinen Punkt gemacht. Und das Kino hat sich kaputt gelacht über diesen Misserfolg und dann kam es zur Situation, in der dachte ich mir, ja gut, dann war es das jetzt. Bisschen peinlich, aber dann kamen ganz grosse Animationen und dieser kleine Stefan-Character wurde so nach vorne und danach wurde grösser geschleudert und dann stand da Herzlichen Glückwunsch mit Null Punkten gewinnt Stefan ein Popcorn. Und das ganze Kino hat gelacht und gejubelt und ich habe ganz da gejubelt, weil ich dachte, ich habe noch nie mit null Punkten gewonnen. Wie cool ist das denn?
Und auf meinem Handy habe ich dann auch gesehen, ah, jetzt habe ich so einen Coupon bekommen.
Und dann bin ich unter dem ganzen Jubel des Kinosaals aufgesprungen, um mir Popcorn zu holen.
Wie geil ist das denn gewesen?
Ah, mega gut.
Mein Learning ist, einfach mitmachen.
Ja, auch mit null. Einfach mal irgendwelche dreckigen Apps runterladen, auf dein Handy zu ballern, da sämtliche Daten von dir preisgeben, um dann mitzumachen bei solchen Spielen. Aber sehr schön, wir dann auch schamvoll des Popcorn entnehmen müssen. Ah, Sie sind Stefan mit null Punkten. Sie Idiot! Ja, einfach schön noch mehr. Wann hat das so zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht schon Popcorn? Nein. Du kaufst kein Popcorn vom Kino, weil ich dachte mir, okay, du hast schon eine grosse Packung Popcorn und gehst dann nochmal mit dem Popcorn raus um dir noch mehr Popcorn. Du das einfach in die alte Box rein. Ich bin nicht so ein Kinosnacker, ehrlich gesagt. Also ich bin eher ein Primär-Snacker und Sekundär-Kino-Zuschauer. Eigentlich, ich denke mir oft so, ich habe jetzt mein Popcorn schon vergessen, ich kann ja gehen. Ach nee, ach ja, stimmt, Javier Badem. Den wollte ich auch noch sehen. Badem, Badem. Da wollte ich auch noch mal ran und nee, ich liebe das. Aber warum nicht, willst du dich nicht abgelenkt sein oder willst du das nicht in dich reinschmelzen? Ach ja, na ja, ich bin nicht so ein Riesenfan. Oder ist es respektlos gegenüber despektlos gegenüber des Films? Ich finde, doch, ich liebe auch den Geruch und so, das gehört für mich alles dazu. Ich bin nur kein großer Fan von den deutschen Snacks. Oft gibt es auch kein salziges Popcorn, gibt es ein süsses Popcorn und dann gibt es irgendwie nur auch Nachos und Popcorn. Und ehrlich gesagt, klar, wenn man in Amerika ist oder so, wo wir da beim Kino waren, da ballert natürlich alles in mich rein, die Chicken Fingers und diese kleinen Mini-Hotdogs und die Pretzel Bites, dafür bin ich zu haben, diese Cinnamon Buns, das ist alles geil, würde ich mir alles kaufen, aber in Deutschland die Snacks reisen mich nicht vom Hopper und da kann ich auch gut Nein sagen. Genau, da habe ich dieses Popcorn gewonnen, da bin ich dann noch rausgerannt, währenddessen ging der Film los, weil ich ein bisschen merkelig fand, dass die mich dann so rausgelotst haben. Und dann habe ich dann nervös Popcorn geordert und wollte dann halb süss, halb salzig bekommen. Und das hat die gar nicht verstanden, diese Frau. Oh Mann, ey, wir sind in der Steinzeit. Deutschland lebt in der Steinzeit, wirklich. Es ist die beste Art, Popcorn zu essen, süss und salzig, du erkennst vor allem die Leute daran, die sich auskennen, sind nämlich die, die Schichten dann einschütten. Weil das Schlimmste, was du mal natürlich machen kannst, ist süss und salzig und dann erste Hälfte süss und dann salzig obendrauf. Nein, und das habe ich einmal gesehen, dass mich eine Kinomitarbeiterin bedient hat, wo ich sagte, das ist eine Meisterin ihres Fachs, die wirklich eine Schaufel süss, eine Schaufel salzig mischen. Eine Schaufel süss, eine Schaufel salzig mischen. Und Ich dachte mir, unglaublich. Marry me. Ja, heirate mich, ich will damit Leben lang nur noch Popcorn aus deiner Hand essen. Und es war wirklich grossartig. Wirklich, mit grossen Augen habe ich dieser Meisterin ihres Fachs zugeschaut, wie sie auf der Leinwand des Popcorns ein Meisterwerk gezaubert hat. Ja, ich habe bekommen drei Viertel süss und obendrauf ein Viertel salzig. Ja, aber es ist tatsächlich ein Argument, ich dachte, du isst keine Snacks, weil du dem Film Respekt zollen möchtest. Nein. Weil es war ja tatsächlich so, als Schinders Liste in die Kinos kam, war verboten, dazu Popcorn auszugeben. Man hat sich generell darauf einig, nicht Popcorn zu verteilen zu Schindlers Liste, weil es respektlos wäre, was natürlich jetzt nochmal eine komplette Popcornpackung aufreißt zum Thema, also alle anderen Filme sind dann egal, jeder andere Film zu jedem anderen Thema, das schwere Themen behandelt, der Pianist, alles ist alles egal, da ist Popcorn erlaubt, nur Schindlers Liste, einzige Film, den man Respekt zollen muss, ist natürlich auch schwierig. Wenn du einmal diese Unterscheidung aufmachst, musst du es auch durchziehen eigentlich. Ja, das ist wirklich merkwürdig. Wofür zieht man das dann durch? Ja, das ist schwierig. Aber ich weiß, wenn ich mal eine Screwball-Comedy rausbringen werde, einen Film, Curfball-Comedy mit den Vengaboy-Soundtracks,
würde ich auch sagen. Ich möchte, dass aus Respekt kein Popcorn verkauft wird. Aber auch aus Respekt, ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast, haben wir ja letztes Mal auch schon drüber gesprochen, Alec Baldwin hat ja eine Kamerafrau erschossen, bei einem schrecklichen Unfall, beim Dreh, ganz, ganz furchtbar, für alle Beteiligten, und da, weiß nicht, ob man da auch aus Respekt sagt, bitte kein Popcorn, dann... Ich glaube, den Film wird es nicht geben mehr, ganz ehrlich gesagt. Der wird komplett abgebrochen. Ich glaube, der wird... Wer will denn Alec Baldwin weiter spielen? Aber weißt du, was das für eine Situation war? War das so... Ich weiß nicht, ich fand das die schlimmste Geschichte aller Zeiten. Super unangenehm. Furchtbar. Und es ist so häufig so ein Scheiß damit passiert, mit diesem dreckigen Mündungsfeuer.
Es geht darum, dass man quasi, ja, man hat Schreckschusspistolen, und die sind auch sau gefährlich, weil was im Lauf sein kann und so weiter. Du hast ja auch kleine Explosionen, damit du halt authentisches Mündungsfeuer hast, dann on screen. Aber ganz ehrlich, im Zeitalter, wo du halt einfach literally die grössten Schlachten der Welt von weirden Cyberwesen so bei Avengers Endgame und so zeigen kannst, kannst du einfach Mündungsfeuer digital erzeugen. Das braucht man jetzt nicht unbedingt. Und es ist so selts, also wie nervig, dass es dann, wie schlimm es zu Unfällen kommt, die einfach vermeidbar sind. Und da war dann irgendwas im Lauf, oder wie? Und er hat die dann durch die Kamera erschossen, oder was? Er hat vor allem die Kamerafrau erschossen und den Regisseur, der liegt immer noch auf einer Intensivstation, wo man auch nicht genau weiß, ob er es schaffen wird. Das heißt, er hat zwei Menschen geschossen. Jesus, aber es ist ja auch nicht seine Schuld, oder? Erschossen. Nein, das weiß man noch nicht. Also Ermittlungen laufen ja noch, aber glaubt man nicht. Und es kann halt sein, dass da drin noch irgendwie so eine CO2-Patrone sich gelöst hat und im Lauf zerberstet ist und alle Richtungen, also es ist ganz, ganz schrecklich. Also es ist natürlich das Schlimmste der Welt.
Und was kurz vorher passiert ist, ist, dass ein russischer Schauspieler auf einer russischen Bühne von einer Bühne, von der Kulisse erschlagen wurde.
Und das sind die schlimmsten Orte, das ist noch ein bisschen verzwickter, weil bei der anderen Situation weißt du sofort, hier ist gerade ein Unfall passiert, wir holen jetzt Krankenwagen und Helikopter und wir versuchen alles Menschenmögliche, um diese Person zu retten. Auf der Bühne, beim Theater, ist nicht unbedingt bei Schauspielern, die verletzt werden, nicht unbedingt klar, ob das gerade zum Spiel gehört oder nicht. Und dann war das irgendwie auch so eine weirde Szene und dann wurde das Kulissenteil umgekippt und so und im Publikum checkt niemand, was gerade los ist. Wenn der so ein riesiges Kulissenteil umkippt und einem Schauspieler auf den Kopf fällt, denkt man, das ist Teil der Aufführung. Ich glaube nicht, dass es so eine Situation war, wo ein Schauspieler allein auf der Bühne war und ihm das was auf der Bühne auf den Kopf gefallen, sondern es ist irgendwo hinter der irgendwie
da war eine größere Kulisse
und so und der hat vielleicht irgendwo hintergestanden
und so und da ist eine Säule umgekippt. Ich weiß nicht, ob man
sofort checkt, aber es soll gerade nicht
so sein. Erstmal spielen ja auch alle anderen
ein bisschen weiter, weil wenn du jetzt
am anderen Bühnenende stehst und hast jetzt Text,
dann natürlich versuchst du es zu überspielen. Ja, klar.
Also wenn ich an meinen Highschool, ich denke,
habe ich sofort weitergemacht im Text. Das lernst du in jeder Schauspielschule erstmal weitermachen. Nicht immer, was ist da passiert? Alles okay? Nee, Florentin, wie gesagt, spiel bitte einfach weiter. Schrei nicht über die ganze Bühne, was ist da passiert. Ich dachte, vielleicht hat jemand was gewonnen oder so. Nur weil Nina gerade fucking Handy guckte. Ach schön, okay. Im Sommer unseres Herrn. Aber es ist krass, ich war auch einmal mit dem Deutscher K in Wien und dann wollten wir Faust sehen und natürlich für uns war das ja wie Rock'n'Roll, das war ja wie Jimi Hendrix, einmal Faust zu sehen für den Deutscher K und dann hieß es auch Tag davor, ja tut mir leid, liebe Schüler, aber ich muss euch mitteilen, Mephisto hat sich das Bein gebrochen. Und wie erst mal, wuuuuh, nimm das, nimm das, den mögen wir nicht, stirb, faust siegt und dann der Lehrer, nein, nein, nein, jetzt im Ernst, Leute, der wird nicht auftreten können. Also wir können jetzt nicht das Stück sehen. Aber faust geht's gut? Geht's Faust gut? Faust geht's gut. Gretchen ist leicht angeschlagen, aber ansonsten geht's allen gut, also wunderbar, von daher überhaupt kein Problem. Haben wir ein anderes Stück gesehen? Mephisto hat sich's Bein gebrochen. Was auch in der Situation, auch auf der Bühne, auch auf der Bühne, wo wir natürlich alle in unserem kindlichen Wahnsinn dachten, fuck, da wären wir gerne bei gewesen, aber da sowas mal zu erleben, aber ansonsten natürlich auch blöd. Geht man dann einfach und sagt, tschau, das war's.
Er ist wie einen Herzinfarkt zu bekommen während so einer Scharaderunde, so einer Activity-Runde.
Das ist die schlimmste Situation. Deswegen immer sagt, macht ein Safe-Word, falls jemand einen Schlaganfall bekommt, wäre ein Tabu, einfach damit ihr ein Save-Word habt, damit klar ist, was los ist. Gibt es, steht das in der Packungsbeilage von Activity drin, dass man sich ein Save-Word überlegen muss? Auf jeden Fall. Ich finde es nicht trivial. Auf jeden Fall. Ich finde es nicht trivial, dass man da jetzt einfach sterben könnte bei. Ja, auf jeden Fall. Aber das ist natürlich eine unangenehme Situation für alle. Wollen wir das mal in die Packungsbeilage, sagt man nicht so. In die Spielanleitung? In die Spielanleitung reinschreiben lassen. Dass wir an Hasbro schreiben und sagen, uns ist da letztens was gekommen. Leute lieben diese Nachrichten bei so Produktfirmen. Ich hatte letztens eine Idee. Wir hatten es letztens über euer Spiel. Wir hatten es letztens über, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt. Siehe Mail. Oh Gott. Und, das hat man immer gern gemacht, dass der Betreff in die Mail übergeht. Wir hatten es letztens über und unten in der Mail steht dann weiter über euer Spiel. Ja, bin ich kein Fan davon. Gar nicht. Aber ist das unser Lebensziel jetzt noch? Ist das unsere
grösste Agenda, dafür zu sorgen?
Vielleicht steht so ein Hinweis auch schon drin.
Macht ein Safe-Board aus. Weiß ich nicht.
Wenn jemand erst auf krank ist, kann das ein Problem führen.
Ja, das ist genauso wie bei der V mit der
Fernbedienung, dass da schreibt irgendwie,
wenn sie ein Aquarium haben,
schauen sie,
bitte, bitte, bitte, dass sie nicht in Richtung des Aquariums mit ihrer Wieschleuder. Der muss auch die Fischlobby geschrieben haben. Ich habe aber zu viele Fische gestorben. Obwohl, Moment, das ist natürlich Verschwörungstheorie, aber will die Fischlobby nicht eher, dass viele Fische sterben? Also jetzt mal, ich habe jetzt einfach mal die Rute ausgeworfen. Ich habe jetzt von der Fischlobby gesprochen. Ach die Fische in einem Aquariumhochhaus, anzugtragende Fische. Ach so, verstehe. Die sagen, nee, so nicht. Die oben bei den Hechten, da müssen sie zu den Hechten hochgehen. Aber ich dachte jetzt, okay. Die Wälder machen draußen das Gebäude sauber. Das sind so die Fensterputzer. Ja, ich dachte, das ist natürlich der ewige Kampf zwischen Fischlobby und Fischverkäuferlobby,
die möglichst wollen, nein,
sag denen, die sollen das Aquarium
direkt vor die Wielfernbedienung
stehen.
Nee, sag denen,
schön, wenn die die Dartscheibe installieren,
mach auf die Dartpackung,
mach die Dartpackung übers Aquarium drüber.
Mach das.
Aber das können sie doch nicht machen, die Fische sterben sterben werden. Tun Sie es einfach! Mehr Geld für uns! So ein Chef will ich auch sein, glaube ich. Ich will auch so ein Chef sein. Dann will ich mit einer dicken Zigarre und einem schlecht sitzenden Anzug und einer hässlichen Krawatte und dann richtig so mit einer Halbglatze und dann immer schwitzig sich totlachen. Oder halt einfach ein Aquarium im Büro haben.
Ja, kann auch sein.
Das wäre natürlich auch geil.
Ich habe jetzt ein Video gesehen von Angela Merkel.
Ist jetzt YouTuberin geworden.
Sie scheint, ist jetzt TikTokerin geworden.
Richtig, genau.
Ich habe eine Roomtour gesehen von ihr im Kanzleramt, weil ich mal wissen wollte, wie arbeitet die da und wie wird das neue Büro von Olaf Scholz aussehen, wenn er da einzieht.
Wie läuft das überhaupt da ab? Wie läuft das ab?
Normalerweise wohnt ja auch die Bundeskanzlerin, die Bundeskanzler im Bundeskanzleramt, sie nicht, sie wohnt weiterhin in ihrer Privatwohnung.
Wir sehen vielleicht von unserem Fenster aus hier gerade.
Und dann hat sie auch gesagt, der Tisch ist mir zu groß, der Schreibtisch, ist ein wuchtiger Boss-Schreibtisch.
Und kein Aquarium gibt es da in dem Ding, in dem Bundeskanzler-Office. Das ist ein sehr guter Blick auf den Reichstag, sehr guter Blick auf das Abgeordnetenhaus. Also man hat so die Demokratie im Blick durch die Fenster. Sehr, sehr schön gemacht. Symbolisch und tatsächlich. Und sie hat sich dann immer zum Arbeiten an den grossen Konferenztisch gesetzt, was ich sympathisch sich nicht, der Tisch war irgendwie zu bossy. Ja. Aber ich werde mich natürlich an den Tisch immer. Natürlich. Klar, das Erste, was ich machen würde, ist erstmal die Füsse hochlegen und einfach sagen, einfach Leute Geheimnisse sagen lassen. Lass mal den BND-Typen herkommen. Was habt ihr denn damals gemacht? Ne, erzähl mal. Ne, sag mal. Ne, sag mal, jetzt mal im Ernst, damals bei Mauerfragten. Die sagte mir jetzt mal., gib mir mal alle Ufo-Akten. In Deutschland muss doch auch schon mal ein Ufo abgeschürzt sein, oder? Irgendwas, sowas wird es noch geben. Das könnt ihr mir nicht erzählen. Was ist das deutsche Area 52? Ja. Das ist die A52. So was, A52 Richtung Bottrop, wo einfach mal irgendwas Merkwürdiges auf der Autobahn liegen geblieben ist. Das ist auch so das Binge. Area 51 würde hier halt heißen. Ach, 51, ne? Sorry, Entschuldigung, ich denke schon im Sequel, ich denke schon in 50. Ja, wo die zwei ein Dollarzeichen ist. Aber hier so Area 51 wäre in Deutschland wahrscheinlich einfach ausserirdischen Vorfall. Ja, ja. B13. AV. Ach so. EV. Ja. Naja, genau. Ebenfalls dachte ich so, ein bisschen boring ist das Büro schon, es war einfach ein sehr, es war, es war ein boring Büro, ehrlich gesagt, wie so eine, von so einem Versicherungsabteilungsleiter.
Aber spielen die sich nicht auch Streiche, so die Kanzler, dass sie dann irgendwie da dann irgendwie sowas liegen lassen, irgendwie so dann irgendwie so so ein Tötungsauftrag irgendwie von jemandem und dann so das Blatt einfach in die Schublade tun, als hätten die jemand umbringen lassen. Oder einfach so eine Schrotflinte, dass man den einfach so eine Art Zeitreiseknopf da installieren lässt. Nee, mach da mal so einen roten Knopf irgendwie, wo drüber steht, nur im Notfall drücken. Mach einfach den Knopf, der führt zu nichts. Aber lass den Olaf mal gucken, wann er den drückt. Oder? Scheiss drauf. Scheiss drauf. Oder einfach good old Furzkissen. Ja, good old Furzkissen oder good old Fisch hinter die Heizung. Das klappt immer, das ist immer witzig, da kannst du immer einen Lacher mit rausholen. Und dann haben die auch eigene Köche da im Bundeskanzleramt und Köchinnen, die da für alle Beteiligten kochen. Und besonders gut kocht wird es natürlich, wenn irgendwie international andere Stabschefs am Start sind.
Und da hatte ich auch einen spannenden Beruf.
Aber die müssen... Die können auch umbringen.
Ja eben, ich dachte mir auch so, wenn die halt Giftmischer, wenn du da Giftmischer reinlässt, dann hast du echt ein Problem.
Da musst du aber schon, das ist schon Longcon.
Giftmischer lässt man da nicht rein. Ja, also nicht zu viele. Das ist ein Denkfehler. Wenn du Giftmischer bist, dann musst du erst mal Ausbildung zum Koch machen. Und dann musst du wahrscheinlich in einem Fünf-Sterne-Hotel oder sowas kochen, um dann irgendwie kochen, aber du darfst es nicht zu sehr wollen. Weil die sagen, sie wollen unbedingt für die Kanzlerin kochen. Warum denn?
Nö, nur wenn es passt.
Ja, je nachdem, wer da kommt, aber die werden...
Ah, scheiße.
Ich bin Giftmischer.
Ich bin Gimi.
Ich bin Gimi aus Russland, fängt euch. Und dann so deine ganze Karriere, egal, so. Ah, fuck.
Ah, nee. Jetzt habt ihr das erraten. Wie viele Agenten auf dem letzten Schritt, in den letzten Metern dann einfach noch gescheitert sind. Wir sind auch im Weg hierher auch am Bundesnachrichtendienst vorbeigelaufen. Oh ja, die haben alle ganz skeptisch aus dem Fenster geguckt, als wir vorbeigefahren sind. Mit zuknitzenden Augen und ganz viele Jalousien sind sie zugeschnappt. Wir sind nämlich ganz langsam vorbeigefahren, wir sind heute zusammen Auto gefahren, wir sind ganz langsam vorbeigefahren. Und wir haben schon gesehen, wie einige Monitore, oh, schnell den Tab gewechselt haben, wir haben da kurz reingeguckt und alle so, ah, dubdi-dubdi-du, ganz schau, was ist denn, was machen wir hier, gar nichts, Mittagspause, ah, ich leg mich hin, ich leg mich kurz auf meinem Schreibtisch schlafen, ah, und dann wir fahren weiter und dann, okay, jetzt geht's weiter. Das Gebäude war sehr unauffällig, es war betont unauffällig. Ja, es war zu unauffällig. Ehrlich gesagt ja. Und ich glaube, wenn man sich da hinstellt, was hält mich denn der Verlaub, mich einfach den ganzen Tag da hinzustellen und zu gucken, wer geht da rein, wer geht da raus? Weiß ich nicht, aber wahrscheinlich kommen genauso viele Menschen rein wie raus. Wahrscheinlich wirst du bald beobachtet werden. Und dann gibt's irgendjemanden, der dann den beobachtet, der dich beobachtet. Aber es ist ja erlaubt, man kann sich einfach neben den Bundesnachrichtendienst stellen. Aber Stefan, du glaubst ja nicht allen Ernstes, dass da wirklich der Bundesnachrichtendienst ist. Wenn ich der Bundesnachrichtendienst wäre, würde ich sagen, baue irgendwo in der Innenstadt, riesiges Gebäude, schreibt da groß drauf Bundesnachrichtendienst, und wir sitzen irgendwo in Ulaanbatu am Strand und machen da unseren Job. Damit die dumme Bevölkerung des Walfi da irgendwie vorbeitrabt jeden Tag und denkt,
oh, hier ist unser Nachrichtendienst.
Ne, wir sind woanders, wir sind in der Cloud.
Angenommen stellt sich jetzt jemand hin zum Podcaster und guckt den ganzen Tag, ob da
auch wirklich genug Leute rein.
Das ist ja ein Großgebäude, ne?
Wir sind ja ein Bundesnachrichtendienst, da haben wir ein großes Bürogebäude.
Ja.
Ja, da müssen da Leute auch theoretisch rein und raus gehen. Ja, aber mal vielleicht nicht über die Straße. Flerst du, dass du, dass du, dass du, dass du, dass du, dass du, dass du, dass du, Ihrem Podcast den Bundesnachrichtendienst zu Fall bringen? Ja, laden Sie doch mal eine Folge hoch. Laden Sie doch gerne mal eine Folge. Kontrollieren Sie das Internet.
Laden Sie das Interview doch einfach mal hoch auf Soundcloud.
Ja, wie wollen Sie mich hin denn?
Schauen wir mal, welche Kommentare da kommen.
Okay.
Und hochgeladen.
Schauen Sie mal, ob Kommentare da sind.
Ein Kommentar vom Bundesnachrichtendienst.
Gefällt uns nicht.
Och nee, können Sie ihn löschen?
Nee.
Die schießen ja echt mit einer Minute nach Upload direkt.
Nee, aber das fand ich schon sehr beeindruckend, gerade das grosse Gebäude. Riesengross. Schön auch, schönes Gebäude, toll. Naja, was ist denn da so die Day-to-Day-Arbeit, das habe ich mich gefragt. Das ist die Frage, wir haben viele Nachrichten bekommen vom Bundesnachrichtendienst, die wir allerdings nicht vorlesen dürfen. Wir hatten es ja letztens drüber und haben über deinen Kumpel gesprochen, der dann Besuch bekommen hat von Agentinnen und Agenten, die dann interviewt wurden, die ganzen Freunde. Und es gibt, ich möchte den Namen nicht nennen, aber es gibt jemanden, der hat Ähnliches erlebt und wurde auch interviewt, aber da kam es dann tatsächlich zu einer erfolgreichen Anstellung beim BND. Also der hat dir geschrieben, anders als bei dir nicht versaut worden. Ich habe gestern überlegt, vielleicht musste er auch einfach sagen, es hat nicht funktioniert. Das ist auch geil. Ja, das stimmt. Oh ja, ich habe es leider nicht bekommen. Ich arbeite jetzt bei einem namenlosen Unternehmen, das langweilige Dinge macht. Genau, er hat nämlich jetzt einen langweiligen Job. No offense, falls du es hörst. Nichts gegen Coca-Cola, aber ich meine, Kohlensäure in Zuckerwasser reinpumpen. Wie konnte das eigentlich passieren, dass Menschen völlig selbstverständlich akzeptieren, dass Kohlensäure in ihren Softdrinks ist? Dass sich dann nicht irgendein Marketing-Typ mal gesagt hat, lass uns das vielleicht mal anders nennen, als Kohlensäure. Selbst auf dem
Werbe steht drauf,
irgendwie spritzig, mit ganz viel
Kohlensäure. Jeder denkt sich,
okay, cool, aber wie konnte das denn
unter dem Radar durchlaufen?
CO2-Patronen habe ich ja jetzt auch bei mir
zu Hause stehen, für so eine Solar-Stream-Maschine.
Will ich nicht.
Ich meine, alles hat irgendwelche euphemistischen
Namen, dass du nicht
Säure aussprechen musst. Alles hat irgendwie
was Cooles, aber
Aber Will ich nicht. Ich meine, alles hat irgendwelche euphemistischen Namen, dass du nicht Säure aussprechen musst, alles hat irgendwie was cooles, aber nicht Kohlensäure. Kann man da nicht einfach mal Fizzy Stuff oder Fizzy Whizzy oder jetzt mit der Diesel- Blubberblasen.
Ja, Blubbi oder irgendwie sowas, dass du da sowas mal machen kannst, anstatt dessen Kohlensäure.
Wollen Sie stilles Wasser oder Make Blubber?
Ach ne, dann hätte ich mehr mit Blubber, das klingt ganz gut. Besseres Blubber steht für Kohlensäure! Die lügen euch alle an! Die lügen euch alle an! Wir haben Probleme mit verrückten Menschen hier. Nein, glaubt mir! Nein! Blubber kannst du doch zum Beispiel sagen. Sprudel. Sprudel. Stimmt. Sprudel, die Sprudellobby. Mineralwasser. Die fucking Sprudellobby. Die versuchen das Wort zu unterdrücken. Sprudel finde ich gut, aber Mineralwasser, da ist noch mehr Mineral drin. Ja, ein bisschen mehr Mineral als sonst. Ja. Aber auch unsichtbar. Aber hat man denn das schon überall reingepumpt, hat man schon versucht, mal in so einen Tee zu packen? Ja. Ja, gute Frage, ja. Hat man da schon mal versucht, in Kaffee zu packen? Milch, ich habe ja eh gedacht, Blubbermilch ist die Zukunft. Aber das gibt doch einfach Milchschaum. Weiß ich gar nicht, was es gibt. Du hast so einen Spritzautomaten. Probier du das doch mal aus. Nee, weil da steht es mir draufzen ausprobieren. Ich war ja auch schon davor. Wann war das so Sahne oder so? Sahne mit Kohlensäure? Du bist bei Milch stecken geblieben. Ja, stell dir mal vor, Milch mit Kohlensäure, wie gut das wäre. Spritzig, knackig, erfrischend. Lecker. Okay, das wäre vielleicht wirklich lecker. Ja, ich probiere da mal ein bisschen Rum. Ehrlich gesagt habe ich da auch noch nicht so viel ausprobiert. Ja, oder du tust halt in Cola noch mehr Kohlensäure rein, dass es so richtig lächerlich viel Kohlensäure einfach drin ist. Weißt du, was, finde ich, zu viel Kohlensäure hat? Ginger Ale. Ja, viel zu viel. Ginger Ale. Viel zu viel. Ist mir auch aufgefallen. Deswegen schüttel ich immer, mach auf, schüttel wieder, mach ein bisschen auf.
Ja, und tatsächlich mache ich das auch oft.
Ich mag auch tatsächlich gerne die letzte Hälfte des Getränks nochmal komplett ohne Kohlensäure.
Nochmal so eine Mate, erstmal genießen und dann die letzte Hälfte komplett alles rausschütteln. Drei Tage stehen lassen?
Wie ich da teilweise angeschaut werde, das glaubst du nicht.
Also was ich da an Blicken ernte.
Du erntest ein bisschen Hate.
Ich ernte Blicke, es ist anscheinend für Leute ein Kardinalsverbrechen, Kohlensäure aus Getränken rauszuschütteln. Absolut unvorstellbar für viele Leute, für mich mittlerweile essentiell. Hast du denn so einen Mate-Keller, wo du dann wirklich so in so einem Holzregal die tagealten Martes lagerst, damit die weniger Kohlensäure haben? Leider nicht. Ich bin ja das Anti-Eichhörnchen. Ich kann ja nicht hamstern. Ich bin hamsterunfähig. Alles, was ich kaufe, wird sofort konsumiert. Und ich kann keine Vorräte anlegen. Ich wäre der schlechteste Prepper, der wirklich einfach seine Prepper-Cracker am ersten Tag der Apokalypse einfach alle aufisst. Dr. Prepper. Die Dr. Prepper-Dosen. Einfach schon, ich glaube wirklich, Zombie-Apokalypse, alle schnell den Bunker, schnell den Bunker und nach vier Stunden habe ich alles aufgegessen, bin halt wirklich komplett hinüber, habe das Food-Lirium meines Lebens und alle sagen, ja, was ist jetzt passiert? Ich kenne auch, wenn Leute von Sättigkeitsgefühl sprechen, habe ich das nicht. Ja, verstehe ich. Fülle ja, aber Satt war jetzt nicht. Ja, Appetitlosigkeit, klar. Aber für mich ist auch jede Form von Sattheit nur ein, ah, ich muss doch kurz warten, bis ich weiter esse. Es ist kein, Essen ist zu Ende. Nein, es ist eine Pause. Wenn ich eine Packung, wenn ich dann mal einkaufe oder so, weil ich Freunde erwarte zum Beispiel, so kaufe ich ein bisschen so Snacks ein. Dann sagen die ab oder es bleibt was über oder man nimmt es erst, konsumiert es gar nicht gemeinsam. Es ist sofort weg bei mir. Ich kann Snacks und so, wenn ich Snacks habe bei mir, kann ich die nicht aufbewahren. Am gleichen Tag ist noch alles weg. Das war eine meiner traurigsten, ich finde, Traurigkeit ist dann akzeptabel, wenn es eine filmische Traurigkeit ist, wenn es was Romantisches hat. Und so eine Szene ist passiert, als ich mal, als er allerersten Male Damenbesuch hatte und ich habe halt mein komplettes Leben überdacht. Also damals war wirklich so, fuck, ich habe Simpsons Bettwäsche. Geht das? Kann ich ein Mädchen einladen und dann Simpsons Bettwäsche haben? Fuck, ich brauche neue Bettwäsche. Ich brauche coole Bettwäsche. Marco Polo, Karstadt, ich muss irgendwie Gourmetabteilung, ich brauche richtig coole Bettwäsche, Vorhänge, braucht man Vorhänge, hat man Vorhänge, ich brauche Vorhänge, installiere Vorhänge. Wie spricht man, was machen Hämmer? Was essen Mädchen, was essen Frauen, was kaufe ich? Und dann dachte ich, ja, vielleicht will man dann irgendwie, wenn man, keine Ahnung, einen Film anguckt, was snacken oder so, was habe ich denn da? Und dann habe ich einfach tatsächlich mehr oder weniger alles gekauft. Ich habe einmal alles gekauft im Supermarkt. Ich habe alles, alle schokoladenmässigen Sachen gemacht, Schokokraussis, Schokobongs, dann Schokoküsse, dann irgendwie auch so Schokomilch, halt wirklich aus jeder Kategorie salzig, einmal die Pringles-Chips, einmal die geschnittenen Chips, einmal die geriffelten Chips, von allem eins, weil ich dachte, wenn ich alles da habe, dann weil wenn sie dann sagt, oh, jetzt hätte ich Lust auf Toffee-Fee und ich, ja, sofort, ich habe alles da. Willst du die dunklen oder die hellen? Die großartige kleine Packung, einfach. Ich habe auch aus Manchin schon die Haselnuss rausgenommen, falls sie das ehemundet. Weil du einfach irgendwie auf alles vorbeibst, weil du willst ja so Bonding-Momente, so, was, du liebst auch Toffee-Fee und nicht so, ja, ich liebe Toffee-Fee, mach dieses Arsenal auf und nimm genau die eine Packung raus und dann, ja, ich hab alles voller Toffee-Fees und solche Bonding-Momente wollte ich generieren, indem ich auf alles vorbereitet bin und dann, ich sag mal so, der Abend lief nicht so gut und niederschmettern schlecht, sag ich mal, sie ist dann relativ schnell gegangen und ich habe dann aus Frust und Trauer alle Süßigkeiten aufgegessen alleine. Und ich dachte mir so, das passt gerade zu gut eigentlich, das ist gerade zu passend, das ist wie in einem Film, wo dann am Ende das so der Downfall ist, wo ich dann alles in mich reinschiebe. Rock bottom. Einfach wirklich rock bottom. Nur dass seitdem der Film nicht ein Happy End gefunden hat. Ja, genau. Genau, das ist der, so ein Film wäre das der erste Akt. Genau, ich hänge im ersten Akt so im Sinn, ja, Problem aufbauen und das war einfach zu perfekt, weil ich einfach alles, so alles in mich reinschieben konnte, wie so ein Oktopus aus allen Tentakeln schießen. Aber ganz ehrlich, es klang jetzt nicht an einem schlechten Abend. Nee, alles in allem nicht. Nee, überhaupt nicht. Weil wenn man alles zusammenrechnet, gute Abend. Ja, vor allem das ist ja, also Essen ist ja auch eine leichte Droge, oder? Also sowas wie Schokolade sagt man ja auch so dann irgendwie Dopamin, Serotonin oder sowas. Also das ist ja das gleiche, was Drogen auch machen, halt nur schwächer. Aber es ist im Grunde, also wie viel Schokolade ist ein Schuss Heroin? Und Kokain macht nicht dick. Also, Kokain wirkt stärker und macht nicht dick. Ja, du, ich sag ja auch nicht, dass Drogen schlecht sind, verstehe mich nicht falsch. Ich sag, Drogen sind immer noch die bessere. Kokain ist das bessere Toffee-Fee. Ja, da möchte ich überhaupt nicht widersprechen, da sind wir total auf einer Seite. Aber genug Toffee-Fee ist auch Heroin. Also du hast, ja, vielleicht nicht, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht müsste man wirklich 100 Kilo essen, aber so viel schafft man halt nicht. Aber da habe ich mich wirklich wieder auf dem Pegel hochgefressen, was ja auch geht. Was ja auch geht. Ich finde es super. Ich empfehle es nicht, aber es geht. Es geht voll klar. Ich möchte kurz mal Werbung in einer Sache machen, denn wir gehen wieder auf Tour. Yeah, wir gehen auf Tour. Endlich dürfen wir wieder auf Tour. Ich bin tatsächlich leicht nervös, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Ich bin leicht nervös, ich freue mich riesig. Ich freue mich auch. Aber wir haben lange, lange keine Shows gemacht und jetzt dürfen wir wieder auf die Bühne und ihr dürft endlich wieder zuschauen, euch dicht zusammengedrängt in Räume begeben und wir freuen uns auf euch. Genau, und zwar spielen wir am 30.11. in Hannover unsere erste Show und es gibt noch einige wenige Tickets. Beeilt euch. Aber es gibt nicht mehr viele Tickets, aber es gibt noch welche, das heißt, falls ihr in Hannover oder in der Ecke wohnt und noch nichts vorhabt am 30.11. Es gab jetzt auch super viel Verwirrung und wir können verstehen, dass viele von euch frustriert sind. Wir kriegen auch immer wieder Fragen, wann ist denn jetzt was, welche Show wurde wohin verschoben, aber die nächsten Termine, glaube ich, sind jetzt erstmal fest. Schaut da, googelt das einfach mal auf der Laviartis-Seite, könnt ihr die Termine sehen und dann würden wir uns freuen, wenn ihr vor ihr vorbeikommt. Dann können wir uns endlich wieder sehen. Sehen wir uns alle mal wieder. Was habt ihr denn alle gemacht in der Zeit? Spucken wir uns in die Münder. Ihr müsst erzählen, was ihr gemacht habt, was habt ihr getrieben in der ganzen Zeit? Habt ihr was Neues gelernt? Wie geht's Ronny, wie geht's Rocco, wie geht's dem neuen Welpen, den ihr gekauft habt, den wir uns gezeigt haben, den wir gesegnet haben. Genau, wie geht's eure Corona-Haustieren, wie wir gesegnet haben.
Wie lief es, habt ihr den jetzt erfolgreich im Wald ausgesetzt,
weil ihr keinen Bock mehr habt und gemerkt habt, dass der Hund ziemlich gross wird nach einer Weile. Wie geht's
denen? Hat das geklappt mit dem
Aussetzen? Das wollen wir bei euch erfragen
und wir freuen uns auf euch. Wir freuen uns auf
euch und das wird bestimmt sehr lustig
oder sehr schlecht. Ja, oder, ja,
mal schauen. Peinliche Stille für andere Stunden.
Mal schauen, mal schauen, mal schauen. Ich freue mich. Ich freue mich auch sehr darauf. Ähm, genau. Kommt rum. Kommt rum. Sagt hallo. Sagt hallo. Es wird aber alles auch wieder als Podcast hochgeladen, also ihr müsst nicht kommen. Nee. Aber ihr könnt, wenn ihr wollt. Ja, ich weiß nicht, warum das so sagen. Aber es ist keine Pflicht. Es ist schlechte Werbung. Also wenn ihr nichts macht, dann habt ihr dasselbe halt nur, ohne dass ihr rausgehen müsst. Ihr könnt zu Hause einfach bleiben, auf die Couch, Toffee-Fib. Ihr könnt es auch nach Hause geliefert bekommen, aber ihr könnt auch die Schuhe anziehen und rausgehen. Und ins teurere Restaurant gehen. Genau. Ja. Und, na ja. Ich würde zu Hause bleiben, wenn die Podcast-Folge anhört. Da muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, da kann ich mir schön in der Schlichten hier Badewanne, mach mir ein Glasgürkchen auf, irgendwie alles genauso, wie ich es will. Niemand spricht gegen Glasgürkchen live, bringt gerne ein Glasgürkchen mit. Nee, ich bin mittlerweile fast so weit, dass ich mich selber fermentieren lassen will. Also, es ist tatsächlich so, das wissen die Gürkchenliebhaber unter euch, das Gürkchenerlebnis ist ja sehr, sehr angenehm bis zu einem gewissen Punkt. Du hast die Gürkchenglas, du machst sie auf, du schnabbelst die raus und dann bleibt aber das Glas mit dem Sud übrig. Und ich habe noch nicht genau verstanden, wie ich das entsorgen will, weil ich will nicht einfach das Sudglas in das Altglas hauen, weil irgendwie fühlt sich das falsch an.
Und ich weiss aber auch nicht, ob ich das wegschütten kann, was bleibt da im Abguss hängen, wo kommt das hin, flüssige Sachen sind eh schwer wegzuwerfen. Kurze Geschichte, lange Geschichte, kurz oder auf jeden Fall habe ich sehr, sehr viele von diesen Sudgläsern noch zu Hause stehen gerade. Okay, willst du das alles ein grosses Sudfass packen? Ja, ich dachte mir, warum nicht, wenn ich da bestimmt hundert Gläser davon habe, alles mal in die Badewanne, da ein paar frische Gürkchen dazu und natürlich als grosse Gurke, ich selber, als Big Pickle, bin ich einfach mit dabei mit meinen kleinen Babys. Es sind ja Gurken, es waren ja erst Gurken und dann macht man die in dieses Sud und dann werden die so ein bisschen gläsern. Ja, ich will mich wie so eine Brutmutter fühlen, verstehst du, wie so eine Art Bienenkönigin, dass ich da so dick und fett im Sud liege und um mich herum ganz viele kleine Gürkchen, so meine Babys und die gehen raus. Babys, äh, labt euch, labt euch an meinem Leib, kleine Larven und dann docken die so an mir an und so in den Bauch nahm. Und dann bin ich so, frisst euch satt, frisst euch dick und saftig. Oder wenn du eins nicht magst, dann schmeißt es so raus. Du hast das Nüsst enttäuscht, Nix, verbannt.
So, das ist manche meine Vorstellung.
Und währenddessen läuft so Kamina Burana-artige Musik, schallt durch die Wohnung.
Ja, wie ich so, wie so
Jabba the Hut-mässig mit so Gürkchen
in der Badewanne.
Mieser Solo oder etwas so
schöner.
Ehrlich, so stelle ich mir das vor.
Aber wirst du dann auch so leicht gläsern? Ja, ich glaube schon, man fermentiert schon ein bisschen. Ich glaube, man wird würziger. Ich glaube, du wirst alles ein, wird's Mensch. Das wird dir nicht schaden. Nö, ich glaube, so eine gewisse Würzigkeit. Ein bisschen pikant. Ja, glaube ich schon, dass das reicht. Es ist ja so, wie Obelix, der in Zaubertrank gefallen ist und dann halt nie wieder Zaubertrank trinken musste, so bin ich ins Gürkchenglas gefallen und muss eigentlich nie wieder nachwürzen, weil ich halt einmal richtig durchgewürzt wurde, alle Körperöffnungen einfach mal durchgewürzt. Und es ist sehr ungesund und du kommst danach mit sehr viel Hautirritation. Kann auch sein, aber was für Gürkchen gut ist, kann für den Menschen nicht schlecht sein. Also davon habe ich wirklich noch nie gehört. Davon habe ich wirklich noch nie gehört. Bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob es der Gurke so gut ist. Also ich finde nicht, dass sie gesund danach aussieht, aber nur meine Meinung. Eigentlich muss ich auch sagen, dass viele Behandlungsmethoden von Essen auch wirklich an Qual, also wenn ich mir so eine Rosine anschaue, die sieht nicht glücklich aus. Also so eine Weintraube, so eine saftige, pralle, sonnenverwöhnte Weintraube, mhm, herrlich. Aber so eine Rosine hat man eher so, ach jetzt mein Gott, isst sie doch bitte auf. Das kann man nicht damit ansehen. Das kann man nicht damit ansehen. Das arme Ding. Es sieht aber auch nicht verloren aus. Es sieht auch so aus, wenn man das jetzt lang genug in Wasser legt, wird wieder eine ganz normale Weintraube raus. Das haben wir immer noch nicht getestet, ob Weintrauben auch wieder reversibel sind, dass man sagt, eine knackige Weine, wirklich von der Rosine zur Weintraube. Oder es ist eine Einbahnstraße. Im Prinzip sieht eine Rosine aus wie ein Sith Lord, der die Macht so häufig missbraucht hat und so diese Machtblitze zu lange ausgeschüttet. Also wie so Sith Lord, Palpatine-Trauben. Ich glaube, Rosinen sind auch die bösen Trauben einfach. Na klar. Das sind wirklich die bösen Trauben. Klar.
Die alten eingefallenen Schrumpeltrauben. Aber nichts ist so böse wie du. Dieser Gurkenlord, so ein Gurken, weirder Gurkenlord in dem Sinn. Ja, wie so ein Mutterschiff. Hast du nicht mal so diese Fantasie, dass du so ganz viele kleine Sachen aus dir rausstößt, die dann so wieder zurückkommen und für dich arbeiten? Nee. So dass du so ganz unbeweglich und fett in der Mitte bist und um dich rum arbeiten so Sachen so wie so Bienen um dich rum und du bist so eine Art Hive-Mind und kontrollierst die so halb? Wie ich mich dir vorstelle, ist so ein bisschen so wie Mad Max, so eine Mad Max-Welt. Ja, genau. Bist du so der Gurkenlord. Ja, genau. Du bist in so einem grossen Gurkenfass und leidest die Geschicke. Genau. Und so deine Hände, deine Kopf sind so Kabel und die gehen so raus. Aber kann man mit Gurken nicht auch Strom erzeugen? Oder waren es Kartoffeln oder irgendwas anderes? Aber das ist doch die dystopische Zukunft, wo einfach Gurken die beste Möglichkeit ist, Strom zu gewinnen. Und um die Klimaanlage zu laufen, weil wir werden ja alle verbrennen und zu beheißen werden alle verkohlen und so, bla bla bla. Und dann gibt es aber eine grosse Klimaanlage, die irgendwo gebaut wird und alle Reichen sind dann in dem Gebäude. So ist ein riesiges Gebäude mit Klimaanlage und die Reichen dürfen da rein und die Armen müssen draußen verwelken. Und ein Dach ist eine große Kartoffel. Genau, ein Dach ist eine riesige Kartoffel, die das Ganze mit Strom versorgt. Und dann brauchst du aber so eine Art so Bio-Priester, die dann diese Kartoffel immer einreiben und bewässern und dann irgendwie so mit so Sud und wo dann so wirklich so Kinder müssen püriert werden für die Salbe, für die Kartoffel.
Ich rede jetzt in der Mad Max dystopischen Zukunftszeitung. Ist mir aufgefallen. Wo dann
Menschenopfer gemacht werden müssen, damit diese
Kartoffel eingereiben wird,
damit die weiter Strom erzeugt.
Für Funny Fresh, den Gott.
Ja genau, vielleicht ist es so eine Kultur,
das ist vielleicht so eine Kultur,
die vergessen hat, wie das funktioniert und die das dann eher nicht wie so ein Ingenieur technisch wartet, sondern eher verehrt, weil man schlicht nicht weiß, wie diese Kartoffel das macht und deswegen sich entschieden hat, wir schneiden jetzt nicht auf und gucken, was da drin ist, sondern wir verehren die und dadurch wird es eher so eine Art Technogottheit, weil niemand mehr weiß, wie es funktioniert. Das wäre eigentlich nicht schlecht. Finde ich ganz gut. Finde ich ganz gut. Und dann draußen und unser Held ist vielleicht dann aber jemand, der draußen geboren wurde vielleicht. Kann unser Held so ein Straight Man sein, der diese Welt einfach absurd findet wie wir, der die ganze Zeit so denkt, what is happening? Vielleicht auch jemand, der so aufgewacht ist, erst in der Zeit, der irgendwie so Walt Disney-mäßig so eingefroren war. Ja, so eine Art Zeit oder so ein CERN-Wissenschaftler, der da in den Dimensionsriss reinfällt und dann da plötzlich ist. Moment, hier ist alles genau wie bei uns, nur halt so eine wilde Kartoffel. Ich finde ganz geil, es ist so eine Schulklasse und die wurden alle eingefroren, weil damals alle eingefroren wurden und jetzt gibt es auf der Welt so wenig Strom, dass deren... Die langsam auftauen. Die werden aufgetaut, weil... Die werden nicht automatisch auf, weil dieser Stromquart nicht mehr dafür zur Verfügung gestellt wird. Und dann macht diese Klasse auf, so eine Highschool, so eine Troy Bolton Highschool Musical artige Klasse. Und unser Protagonist ist eine ganze Highschool-Klasse, oder was? Ist ein Ensemble-Film, ja. So ein Highschool-Musical, so gut gelaunte Basketball-Jocks und Girls. Und die reisen dann durch diese Welt in so einem alten Schulbus, den sie gefunden haben, und kommen dann zu der Kartoffelwelt, die diese Kartoffel einreiben. Genau, und dann alle sagen, niemand weiss, wie das funktioniert. Und Ashley sagt, aber das haben wir doch letztens in Physik, wir haben doch letztens das Experiment gemacht im Unterricht. Und die sind die einzigen, die verstehen, wie die Kartoffel funktioniert und können aber nicht rein, weil die halt zu der niederen Klasse gehören und die kommen nicht in das Gebäude und könnten denen helfen und dann... Und dann sagt Imperator Furiosa sagt, ihr könnt hier nicht rein. Aber wir haben das letztens in Physik gemacht, ich habe nur zwei geschrieben. Okay, okay, Ashley, du darfst zu uns hochkommen. Okay, macht's gut, ihr Loser. Macht's gut, ihr Loser. Das ist einer der ersten One-Take-Filme der Filmgeschichte. Da liegen halt auch viele Blooper und Sprichfiele mit drin. Bleiben du drin. Ich komme noch mal rein. Macht's gut, ihr Loser. Einmal noch. Macht's gut, ihr Loser! Nice. Und dann folgen die. Und es sind auch quellend lange Gänge, leider, lange Korridore, weil das Set riesengroß war. Eschne geht rein, macht das grüne Kabel links rein, das rote Kabel rechts rein. Und plötzlich und es wird so kalt, dass die Upper Class Gefahr läuft zu erfrieren und sie sagen, schnell, schnell, Imperator Gurkenlord, wir müssen die Schleusen öffnen, die Kälte muss nach draußen, sonst erfrieren wir. Ihr habt mich enttäuscht. Ihr habt uns alle enttäuscht. Aber was sagt ihr, Lord, Schleusen auf oder nicht? Ja. Mach die Schleusen auf! Und dadurch kommt die ganze kalte Luft von innen dem Gebäude auch nach draußen. Und auch die armen und die untere Klasse kann auch in Kühle leben und müssen nicht länger sterben. Gut. Gut, das war unser Pit. Wir sind Stefan und Florentin. Ihr erreicht uns unter zentrale-at-podcast-uvo.de
Falls ihr 200
Millionen Dollar rumliegen habt, schaut mal
aufs Sparbuch. Ernsthaft, schaut mal,
Deutschland sucht das Sparbuch, schaut mal auf
euer Sparbuch, ob da noch Geld drauf ist.
Falls ja, dann spendet es an uns,
wir produzieren diesen Film, wenn wir
Zeit haben. Und Lust.
Und Lust. Und wenn wir es noch mal
gut finden. Genau, und sich Stefan
in drei Tagen noch an die Geschichte erinnern kann.
Ansonsten nicht.
Ansonsten wünschen wir euch
vor allem eine fantastische Woche.
Bleibt gesund, legt euch in Sud,
esst Kartoffeln und
schaut mal auf eurem Konto.
Macht's gut, haut rein, habt eine schöne Woche.
Wir heben noch ab.